Bro, there's no way that this actually happened. That's not possible.
Come on. This have to be today, right? But that doesn't matter,
right? That's not her. And by the way, I don't think that's actually
information that was on the internet or would be published somewhere
unless somebody went to efforts to try to dox her. Check out
these docs real quick. Why not?
What's going on here? What's going on with these over here? In
fact, the the most public information that I've seen of the ABMC
person's identity is when Destiny went into his public chat and
decided to say, "This is actually who she is. She here's how
you could try to find her in real life." Like, you understand
there's a massive difference between an online pseudonym and
your full legal name. Right. Right. She used to live with this
person. That was prettyed up of the the person who they're alleging
tries to expose other people's private information as much as
he possibly can with plausible deniability. Yeah, it's pretty
pretty weird. I think that's pretty weird.
Check out these docs real quick. Why not?
What's going on here? What's going on with these over here? Port
listener. Okay, so we got this guy right here. What is this?
This is Pixie supporting the What is this precisely? This is
Pixie supporting. So Pixie filed the protective order. Destiny,
I guess, countered it and now this is them continuing from there.
So, uh, we'll have to refer back, but this is, uh, this is Pixie's
response in support of her motion. So, Desessie did a reply in
opposition. We covered this. I believe this is the one where
we had, um, like they referenced me in here. Non-party witnesses
have not sought anonymity. Yeah, I do remember reading this now.
Yeah, I remember reading it. Okay. Where is Kelly? I can't read.
Uh, I don't I don't know if Kelly's around. Okay. I want to make
sure I don't get this cutting stuff off of the screen here for
one second. All right. Plaintiff Jane Doe's reply to response
to motion for protective order governing discovery. Plaintiff
Jane Doe by and through undersigned counsel. Also, I think um
if if Pixie's lawyers were not upset before, okay, if they weren't
upset before, they're upset now cuz this is just them like Destiny's
case like his lawyers and him to a large extent the whole time.
It's quite funny. Okay, man. Kick chat is sc so scuffed. Is it
really? What's wrong with kickaten? Bad happening over here or
all right. Okay. Plaintiff's motion for protective order is effectively
unopposed.
Oh, sorry. We didn't finish this. Hereby respectfully replies
to defendant Steven K. Benell's response to her motion for entry
of a protective order pertaining to discovery. Plaintiff's motion
protective order is effectively unopposed. Banell does not dispute
that a protective order is appropriate in this case. DE92, which
is the docket entry 92 at two, Banell does not object to the
entry of a reasonably reasonable and narrowly tailored protective
order. So basically, they're saying when when Destiny in the
second paragraph says he doesn't uh actually narrowly Oh, second
sentence maybe. Well, Banell does not object to the entry of
a reasonable, narrowly tailored protective order. So, they're
basically being sassy here and saying he already said, listen,
this is a this is a narrowly defined and uh reasonable protective
order. So they he's basically already said he doesn't care is
a little funny. Reasonable and narrowly tailored protective order.
Nor does he actually challenge the standard language of the proposed
protective order plaintiff submitted documentary 821. Rather
astonishingly, Bennell wastes the court's time in focusing on
a single provision of a prior draft protective order plaintiff
had submitted to Banell's council. And he does so by blatantly
misrepresenting to this court its proposed language while concealing
the distinguishing factors in the authorities he relies on. Okay.
Okay. go off. Specifically, Benell's opposition boils down to
an objection to the request of plaintiff's fact witnesses to
remain anonymous, referring to language that appeared in a prior
draft proposed protective order, not in the broader standard
language contained in the final proposed protective order. As
such, plaintiff's motion is effectively unopposed. However, in
an abundance of caution, plaintiff will address each of Benell's
arguments. So, it's like actually you totally misread the the
document. You are working off of a draft order we proposed from
before. It's not actually the final draft order. though. Since
you're not opposing the final draft order, we're unopposed. So,
this should just be passed. But just in case, we'll respond just
in case you're like a and you want to beg for the court's mercy.
Okay. Now, that's funny because Pixie seems also [__]
up a couple times, but I don't know. It's just funny in general.
Uh, uh, yeah. Plaintiff does not seek to shield discoverable
information from Benell. Banella misconrs plaintiff's positions
in suggesting that plaintiff seeks to shield as undiscoverable
certain information from Banell, such as witness identities.
That is false. The standard language of the proposed protective
order simply seeks to protect sensitive information from public
disclosure which is standard practices standard practice in cases
such as the case at bar. As such, Banel's arguments and case
citations including to Hubard v. Bank Atlantic Bankorp Incorporated
uh and then it's got a citation number are highly misleading.
Not only was the plaintiff's position in Hubard that witnesses
identities are undiscoverable or sorry that witness identities
are undiscoverable despite the fact that witness the identities
of confidential witnesses in securities fraud cases uh securities
fraud class actions are discoverable as a matter of law but the
Hubard plaintiff also incorrectly insisted that the identities
of witnesses are work product and failed to seek any type of
protective order. So they're citing the the case at 35. Banell's
figned confusion over the scope of the proposed protective order
is easily refuted by its plain language. Banel three Banell's
contentions about requests for anonymity are refuted by the record.
Even if plaintiff's proposed protective order constituted an
order that permits plaintiff to unilaterally designate a witness's
identity as confidential.
Um it does not. So order that permits the plaintiff to unilaterally.
So he's arguing that basically we we don't get to say anything
and it will allow you to say every further witness will always
be confidential no matter what. Uh it does not. Banel fails to
disclose to this court that the prior draft order proposed entirely
appropriate language to the effect that the name or identifying
information of non-party witnesses who wish to keep their identity
private shall remain confidential. Documentary 922 at paragraph
2C emphasis added this se this stands in direct conflict to Bedell's
protestation that the witnesses themselves do not even seek to
remain anonymous. Documentary 92 at two. Also contrary to Bedell's
contentions is the fact that plaintiffs witnesses already expressed
under oath that they wish to stay anonymous and that due to the
sensive nature of their testimony, the contents thereof should
not be publicly accessible. Documentary 77 to 79. See also declaration
77, ABMC declaration at paragraph 10 setting forth the reasons
for wishing to remain anonymous. So he basically argued that
they did not do that and they clearly did, right?
So he's saying, oh well the witnesses themselves haven't said
they want to remain anonymous. Well, actually technically a bunch
of these people have said as a part of their affidavit that they
wish to remain anonymous. So this weird and just kind of lying,
but okay. This court already agreed and permitted for these witnesses
to remain anonymous. Documentary entry 75. Banell's frivolous
standing challenge and the right of third party witnesses to
remain anonymous in the cyber harassment action or yeah, cyber
harassment action. Despite the foregoing reality, which entirely
neutralizes Banell's challenges to the proposed protective order,
plaintiff addresses Banell's remaining arguments, including his
inference that plaintiff lacks standing to request that the identity
of certain of her witnesses remain confidential. Courts routinely
fashion protective orders for purposes of shielding sensitive
information about third party witnesses if so requested by a
party to the action. See example, Farnsworth versus Proctor Gamble.
uh affirming blanket protective order issued to protect interalia
identity of witnesses to avoid disclosure of highly personal
embarrassing information. After all, federal rules of civil procedure
26 C provides that a party may have moved for a protective order
to protect any nonparty from annoyance, embarrassment, oppression,
or undue burden or expense. TLO LLC versus pro life
see also HD Sharer LLC versus uh National Molecular Testing Corp.
Okay. Uh under rule 26 C, a party may move for protective order
regardless of whether the moving party is seeking to prevent
disclosure of information by a nonparty. Citation and internal
quotation marks omitted. In fact, contrary to Banell's contention,
courts have recognized that such protection applies especially
to third party witnesses given that these witnesses have not
chosen to avail themselves of public forum of the court. Uh Hineki
versus Santa Clara University. Much like in Planned Parenthood
Arkansas versus Eastern Oklahoma versus Jaggley numbers uh sorry
the citation numbers for example plaintiff's prior draft protective
order simply contemplates that the umbrella type of protection
often fashioned by courts with the opportunity for each witness
to decide whether she/he wishes to disclose their identity. So
the previous cited thing at three reasoning that these third
party witnesses are not individuals who willingly sought to be
involved in this lawsuit that they are third party witnesses
only and if uh and that if any of these third party witnesses
wish to make their identities known publicly nothing in this
court's protective order only order prevents them from doing
so.
Yeah, sure. Do I need to read this again? Especially a third
party witnesses given that these witnesses have not chosen to
avail themselves to the public form of the court. Yeah, that
makes sense, right? So basically like of course these people
could seek protection. They're not actually filing a contention.
In fact, they might not be part of the case at all. Of course
like it would be it would make a lot of sense to give them some
kind of protection to testify, right? To give some evidence towards
getting the right to the case. Why do they keep using ABMC name?
Because it has been a part of the case from the very beginning.
They identified the screen name in the um in the initial disclosures,
right? The screen name AbbyMC was a part of the initial disclosures
and they they just have kept using it through the whole case.
Why wouldn't they keep using it or should do you think they should
not use the screen
And one bone further just because they use the screen name. Do
you believe that that means that that person's real identity
should not be protected from the documents? She wanted to remain
anonymous, I thought. Okay, one bone. I want you to tell me uh
Mr. Medkaker's real name right now. Or who's another person?
I want you to tell me
who's another person who's like totally anonymous. I want you
to tell me like Kersh's real name right now. You don't have to
go to a website and look this up, right? There is there is anonymity
behind a pseudonym. Obviously, I mean his last name. And you
could go look these things up. Don't you think it's easier to
find with her with that name? It might be, but that doesn't matter,
right? That's not her. And by the way, I don't think that's actually
information that was on the internet or would be published somewhere
unless somebody went to efforts to try to dox her, right? Like
she was on a public stream as Abby, but I don't think anybody
ever gave her full name or I don't think her full name was like
spammed around or some [__] Obviously, if you put
it in chat, I would perma banan you. So, don't be a
Okay, one bone. You understand that there's a massive difference,
right? Oh, yeah. Sitch. PSA Sitch, right? Like, you understand
there's a massive difference between an online pseudonym and
your full legal name, right? And that there's a massive difference
between This is the Pixie case. Yes. And there's a massive difference
between publishing the full name like would normally happen in
a court case and a screen name. Do S and Adam still stream? Yep,
they do. They do. They do. Is this one bone guy going to respond?
I think did this did this one bone guy I'm looking to see if
he responded. It's just I want him to just say obviously there's
a huge difference between a pseudonym and a full legal name.
That's pretty clear to everybody. Okay, cool. Cool, cool, cool,
cool. In fact, the the most public information that I've seen
of the ABMC person's identity is when Destiny went into his public
chat and decided to say, "This is actually who she is. She here's
how you could try to find her in real life, right? She used to
live with this person." That was pretty up of the the person
who they're alleging tries to expose other people's private information
as much as he possibly can with plausible deniability.
Yeah, it's pretty pretty weird. I think that's pretty weird.
But hey, that's just me, man. That's just what I think, dog.
Okay.
You win. Uh, Space Ghost 17, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it, dude. Appreciate it. So, um, it's just saying third party
witnesses have obviously like a right, perhaps even more of a
right, to decide whether their identities will be disclosed in
a in a lawsuit. And there's just Destiny's arguments essentially
make no sense, right? Like they really make basically no sense
at all. He he tries to say stuff like, "No, no, no. This is a
how in the world is it a legal argument to say this is a big
boy lawsuit. It's either all in or all out like no I I think
uh there's a lot of concern around this. Hey person that I tried
to dox and advocated for it's a big boy lawsuit. Why would you
need your name protected?
Good one.
Banell also overlooks that these protections apply with special
forces with special force to cases calling for evidence of related
activities as in the case at bar. D example wheels versus human
resource systems inc 17 federal rules of
I don't know if that's federal rules FRD whatever I don't I don't
know I need to figure out a way to actually case case number
reversing order denying motion for protective order by party
on behalf of third party witnesses regarding conduct
indeed the revised rule 412
of the federal rules of evidence now applies to all types of
misconduct cases expressly and expressly extends to third parties
see stalmacker versus kmart citing federal rules of civil uh
federal rules of evidence 412 advisory committee notes four noting
that the revised rules applies in all cases involving misconduct
without regard to whether the alleged victim or person accused
is the party to is party to the litigation. The rule aims to
safeguard against the invasion of privacy, potential embarrassment
and stereotyping that is associated with the with public disclosure
of intimate details and the infusion of innuendo into the factf
finding process. The rule also encourages victims of misconduct
to institute and to participate in legal proceedings against
alleged offenders. Offenders. Oh, so Destiny's lost all of his
claims. Like when any of these people say that Destiny's like
uh victimized themsel, they they pretty clearly would have the
right to summon an anonymity, right? If they're third party witnesses,
the argument you're they're making. Cool. There's no doubt that
rule 412 applies to nonparty witnesses.
Under these safeguards, courts have held, for example, that third-party
testimony about romantic or relationships is highly sensitive
in nature and that disclosures of the witness identities within
their communities would expose them potentially to harassment,
embarrassment, or stigma. Voice of San Diego versus Naval Criminal
Investigative Service. Uh, and then there's a case number. Finally,
there's no support to Benell's insistence that the plaintiff
failed to meet her evidentiary burden to show good cause. As
other courts have concluded under similar circumstances, the
third party witnesses wish to remain anonymous based solely on
their rep representations to that effect to the moving party.
See example, Alaska Committee actions on toxics versus Aurora
Energy Services LLC. This is citation number. Uh rejecting defendants
standing argument and observing that the anonymous individuals
here have indicated to plaintiff representative that they wish
to remain anonymous.
See also Oh Jesus, they've just got so many citations. I'm going
to start skipping by this the citations. Jesus
That's just too much. Vanel's challenges to the meet and confer
process have been waved and are in any event wholly unsupportable.
So, would this have been I don't remember the challenges to the
meet and confer proc uh process. So, maybe we'll have to go back
and check this here. Hold on. Let's see here. Oh, they're both
right here. Also of concern is plaintiff's failure to adequately
meet and confer prior to filing this motion. On May 14th, plaintiff's
council provided the undersign with a draft stipulated stipulated
confidentially confidentiality agreement and protective order.
After receiving plaintiff's draft order, the underside provided
comments in redline format reflecting defendants's proposed revisions
to the draft order. As reflected in exhibit B to the Breler declaration,
Benell's proposed revisions to the draft order were intended
to emit the loophole of the plaintiff created by unilaterally
allowing her to shield the identities of non-party witnesses
and/or potential witnesses. While plaintiff's council acknowledged
that the witness's identities are not inherently confidential,
plaintiff nonetheless insisted upon including language in the
draft protective order that would permit her to unilaterally
mask the identities of her witnesses and/or potential witnesses.
Wow, bro. Did Kick Chat like die again or what? That one bone
guy was gone and then he like never responded. I like asked him
a question. He just pieced the out like instantly. That's crazy.
Oh yeah, Kick is totally [__] God damn it.
Oh well. Oh well. Is what it is. There is no legal basis to shield
witnesses identities from disclosure. Oh, sorry. This the Andrew
Breler stuff. I just want to see what they're talking about with
regards to um meet and convers. Go back to this now. Banell's
challenges to the meet and confer process have been waved and
are in any event wholly unsupportable. Further highlighting Banell's
ill intentions. His opposition raises two confusing challenges
to the party's meet and confer efforts. First, Banell essentially
postulates that a pre-filing conference could have could only
have been proper if the movement had agreed with the non-Movement's
position.
Docket entry 92 at 23. This position defies common sense, especially
because no motion would be necessary if all parties had agreed
to the relief requested following the pre-filing conference.
So, okay. It's like, oh, the meet and confer is invalid because
you didn't say what you disagreed on. Maybe I'm I'm not sure
exactly.
Do I have to go and look at the meet and confer notes? Cuz I
I think um is this where Bretler I believe this might be where
Bettler basically like wasn't responding. was taking a long time
to respond to Joan and she was just like whatever you I consider
our meet and confer efforts exhausted cuz he had like taken a
bunch of time to respond to things. I think that's what this
is. Exhibit B. Yeah. Based on your Dawn response, we can consider
our meet and confer efforts to reach to reach a resolution on
a joint protective order to be exhausted and then they're going
to file a motion. Joan, it's 10:00 a.m. I marked up your proposed
arguments and we'll send uh your comments when I get out of my
meeting. Please see your revisions on to the proposed order.
I think Andrew was late to meeting her. like Andrew had said
he's going to meet her and then he wasn't getting back to her
and yeah, it is what it is. That's what this is talking about.
Okay. Okay. Second, Banell complains about alleged discrepancies
in the proposed protective orders, but he cites to no authorities
for the proposition that a motion for a protective order must
be denied if the final proposed protective order is not identical
to the version previously served. In any event, this argument
has been waved for Banell's failure to adequately brief it. Banell
did not even address it in ar in the argument section of his
responses and fails to elaborate on his position. does not cite
to any authorities in support thereof and does not claim to be
prejudiced by the alleged discrepancies in the draft protective
orders. C. Cavdo versus Iberinius Aras de Espa.
Okay. Some court something. Arguments made in passing not sufficiently
briefed and raised without citing to authorities are deemed waved.
Okay.
The contrary, the only party that is prejudiced here is plaintiff
for being forced to brief an issue contained in a prior draft
proposed order which issue Benell and which issue Banell mischaracterizes.
Irrespective of waiver, Benell's bold proposition that the court
should decline to enter the requested order, documentary entry
92 at 7 on the basis that a prior draft proposed order provides
for anonymity of plaintiff's witnesses if so requested by them
is not only illogical and unsupportable, but smacks of bad faith
and further butresses the fear of plaintiff and other victims
of being further victimized by Benell and his intentions to continue
to harass and threaten them in connection with this litigation.
So, this is funny because this is what he's been saying on stream
is these people want to unilaterally declare like people are
are anonymous and then and then never give me their identities.
He's been like saying this, right? I wonder if they failed to
actually look at the language in one of the updated um one of
the updated like draft orders and responded to an old draft order.
That'd be kind of unfortunate for them. This is a response to
a response. Yes, my Yeah, that is his argument, Kingler. Except
none of those people are actually having their identities hidden.
They're not undiscoverable in any way. And most cases that involve
elements
misconduct cases are actually there is like blanket exceptions
for those people to be to remain anonymous to the public, right,
under the federal rules of evidence. So he is just making that
up that these people want to stay anonymous. He's also created
a fantasy in his head where where a judge would allow or anybody
would allow the identities to be withheld from him if basically
the motion to seal failed in any of these cases and somebody's
identity couldn't be protected. That that identity would be withheld
from him and they would not be discoverable in any way. That
is obviously just untrue. No judge would allow that. That would
be a really bad thing. And if it were true, then I think when
Andrew Breler and Destiny complain about how that's happened
or how they feel like that's happened, a judge would have to
respond and say, "No, no, no. That's not quite what happened.
And actually, it's probably fine, right? Okay. Anyway, yeah,
he loops about this seemingly continuously. It's a little strange.
Yeah, it's I don't I like it's just I I think he's kind of been
blown out on it. He kind of he's just obviously like overplayed
far and he's gone far and above like hyperbole in saying, "Oh,
no. I expect them to be sanctioned." And then he backed it up
to like, "No, they should be reprimanded to like, oh, well, maybe
they won't say anything." Damn. Kick saying true to the name
completely kicked me off the app. Based, we love Kick. Okay.
Kick casually just logged me out. Awesome. You love to see it,
guys. You love to see it. You love to see it. Okay. Banell fails
to site a single analogous
case, tellingly, "None of Banell's cited cases involves allegations
of misconduct, such as cyberh cyber harassment. As such, each
case Benell relies on is uh is inpposite, opposite, and I don't
know what this is. In opposite, in opposite, out of place, inappropriate."
Okay. in opposite and unpersuasive.
Banel's citations to the lines line of cases declining to an
anonymity cuts against his position given that this court has
already found that this is that exceptional case where the plaintiff
may proceed under a fictitious name and her witnesses may submit
declarations under seal without public disclosure of their identity.
See Dovy Frank said it at documentary 92357
case involving allegations of discrimination on the basis of
alcoholism in the Chaita Brands International Inc. case. Uh oh.
at cited at docket entry 92 in a case where for over a decade
hundreds of plaintiffs have litigated this case under their true
names. Nothing in the record suggested that they have faced paramilitary
retaliation. And unlike in this case sealed uh sealed document
entry 77 to 79. In neither instance did this the appellants establish
a sufficient nexus between the claimed threats and the disclosure
of their identities. Okay. Destiny read the case read these cases.
They're these are not they're not the best comps. Yeah, they're
not. But um okay, at no point has Banell disputed that he threatened
plaintiff uh and her witnesses with physical harm in retaliation
to their allegations and testimony in this action or that he
publicly harassed and ridiculed plaintiff's legal team. Documentary
723. In light of the standard language of plaintiff's proposed
protective order, there can be no explanation for Banell's objections.
There too other than that Banell continues to uh intends to continue
to threaten and harass plaintiff, her fact witnesses, and her
legal team. It's like, bro, why don't you say that you didn't
threaten these people? Why don't you say that you didn't actually
say some people should be killed who are apparently parties to
the case or sorry, witnesses on the case? Why didn't you just
say why don't you deny that you did say these people should be
killed or that you did try to harass these people? Why don't
you deny this? And if you don't deny it, then why do you why
are you opposing the protective order unless it's to continue
this harassment? Yeah. Done. Easy. Equally unpersuasive are Bernell's
remaining case citations as none involved remotely analogous
circumstances. See Oregon Socialist Workers 1974 campaign uh
Communications versus Palace
citation number cited at docket entry 92 at 4 anonymity not appropriate
in in action attacking the Oregon campaign disclosure act observing
that in our democracy the voting public is entitled to know what
special interests are behind a potential office holder.
Okay, so it's not a case at all. Uh involving different circumstances
to whether anonymous affidavit were sufficient to support the
plaintiff's trade secrets claim in in summary judgement proceedings.
That's not even remotely analogous. Um involving burden, although
I would like to know how this went, right? It seems like it must
have gone they must have decided that they weren't enough. So
that's interesting. Paramilitary. Yeah, that was Shakita bananas.
Bro, don't you know about banana republics? Don't you know where
the term banana republics comes from? Schumafiend, are you unaware?
Are you unlearn it? Look up that case. Look up which case. Why
would we care about almost any of these cases? This one's like
maybe a little interesting. Could come up later if they go to
summary judgement, but uh we're not there yet, so I'm not super
interested in figuring out what's happening in summary
Uh Rezling, thank you for the 4 month celebration. What's up?
Thanks for the content. No problem, buddy. involving due process
violations in terminating public assistance payments where welfare
recipients were procluded from the witnesses. By contrast is
well settled that particularly in harassment and other misconduct
cases. It is entirely proper for com entirely proper and common
for a plaintiff to rely on confidential witnesses. EART vox news
network LLC citation number noting also that the anonymous witness
testimony would be relevant to plaintiff's claims. C. Hineki
versus Santa Clara University. Citation number. Noting that courts
in the Ninth Circuit have found that allowing victims to proceed
anonymously serves a strong public interest in protecting the
identities of assault victims so that other victims will not
be deterred from reporting such crimes. Noting that the the lack
of prejudice to defendant, especially where defendant had used
the true names of witnesses before and finding that the public
interest is served in allowing an alleged victim of harassment,
to be sued under a pseudonym to avoid deterring other victims
from coming forward. Citation and internal quotation marks omitted.
Okay, initially left blank. That's the end. Okay. Yeah, I'd say
these are all cases Destiny Red. I'm sorry I mistyped. These
are bad comps.
Um, hold on. You understand that these are almost entirely Destiny's
Destiny's citations, right? Destiny Destiny's lawyers cited these
cases. This is not Pixie's legal team citing all these cases.
These are all Destiny's legal team citing these cases. Do you
not Oh, did you try to Did you think you cooked your OFG? He's
pro. Do you think you're like, "Oh, Destiny read these and they're
like bad comps. Why is Destiny's team legal team using them?"
Did he not let them know? Did he not type up some notes and let
them know that these are actually really bad comps? Cuz all of
this documentary 92, these are all like his know. Was Destiny
like reading this and being like, "Oh, they totally me here when
they said that Banell's remaining case citations has not involved
a remotely analogous circumstances." Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Based
that's that's their argument actually. OMFG. He's bro. I can't
I can't imagine Destiny went through and read these and was like,
"Oh, I'm totally in every single case here." But maybe he did.
That's crazy, dude. That guy's actually turning it around. Maybe
he's starting to get a little more objective about things. Awesome.
That's cool that you can actually support Pixie's legal team
here when they say none of these match. None of these matter.
None of them are about this. Yeah, that's cool. Thank you. Uh,
appreciate you. Cool. So, they filed that and we'll see what
happens. I'm guessing that the like protective order will be
pushed through. What's he paying these bozos for? No, he didn't
read those. He read the one about anonymous witnesses and how
they were bad comps. Which which one are you talking about? Omfg.
He's pro. Are you talking about? Cuz you were reading this, right?
You're saying these ones up at the top from like 20 minutes ago.
I don't even know what this talking about. Guess he seems to
resign that he's going to be paying out this lawsuit. Uh I don't
know that he's going to I don't know that Pixie is going to be
awarded damages or he's going to be found liable in this lawsuit.
I actually don't know
Oh, I caught portions of it, but he was talking about how some
of the cases cited. He was thinking that it was Pixie's attorneys.
Wait, there's no way that he actually went through and thought
the same thing OMG he's pro did and that he thought it was Pixie's
legal team that cited this. That's not possible. That would be
too funny. There's no way that he realized,
dude, no shot that he goes through this and realizes that he's
actually Is that
That would be really funny if that exists. We could go look for
it. But if that VOD's not deleted, I call Yeah, I just don't
I don't necessarily think he did that. Starts here, bro. There's
no way that this actually happened. That's not possible. Come
on. This have to be today, right?
Streamed 11 hours ago. Starts here. Wait, didn't you give me
a 3 hours? Bro, why do you guys Why do people link things without
time stamps? That's always crazy. I wonder what they site here
to case from start to finish on any of this or any of the motions
or any of the filings. If they have, they are very good at seeming
like they haven't. Uh there was a is the zip zip. What is that?
What which citation there are you talking from you the defendant
from knowing them? Well, that's never the case, but even sealed
publicly. Um witness identities are typically not publicly sealed
either. They're not by default. Oh, how do I time stamp it? You
right click and say copy video URL at current time. Certainly
not by default. You can file to make a request, but that's not
the default. and you have to make an affirmative argument for
why an identity ought to be sealed. The argument that they keep
trying to make is that these witnesses have like embarrassing
personal information, but they don't have to cite any of that.
There's no reason for him to do that. They just continue to do
it over and over again because the goal is to just defame me
in court filing so that I can't countersuit for it, which is
one of the most important things I think for Pixie.
So, defame me in court filing so I can't countersuit for it.
Hold on. No, no, no, no, no.
Uh, hold on. Destiny could totally actually Destiny could totally
say this is defamatory. I'm going to counter sue. He's actually
just lying here. He absolutely could through his lawyers obtain
their identif like their information and say this is defamatory
and you're you're making it public via these things and he could
totally sue them. Well, actually, hold on. No, no, no, no, no,
wait. That's totally wrong. That's totally wrong. No, no, no.
Hold on. That's totally wrong. I think that would come down to
you would have to litigate that through uh perjury, right? I
think that's actually yes, you'd have to litigate that through
perjury. Hold on. I think that might it might be protected possibly
from defamation and it could be but it would be under perjury
if it was false. It's not false though. That's the thing. I don't
I don't think that any of those statements are false as far as
I know. I think he reads through like three or four of the cases
cited. So, we'll see. Cases to just constantly defame me. She
even brought that up in the um in the hearing in the uh that
we had that they um cried and moaned to get the transcript sealed
on that they're trying to get the transcript permanently sealed
on the um she brought up that like oh like I think he sent this
video to an underage girl she was 17 and I was like you have
no idea you have no idea what the [__] you're talking
about but okay um what
kind of cyber harassment like offer nothing at the record show
any intentional harass or anything but cases
of allegations of cyber harassment because like offer nothing
to the record to show any intentional harass or anything there.
But okay, wait cyber harassment would be like the Florida statue.
He's saying none of the cases you cited the the lawyer is saying
none of the cases you cited are actually like relevant to this
case. They aren't the same like
you know vaguely the same area of case law. Page three and argument
four. Unlimited ending challenge and the right of witness to
remain anonymous in the cyber harassment action. Despite the
forgoing reality which entirely neutralizes challenges protected
or plaintiff addresses remaining argument including infr standing
to request of certain her witnesses court routinely fashion protective
order for purposes of shielding sensitive information about third
party witnesses if so requested by a party to the action. Um
and then they cite this case pro affirming um blanket protective
order issued to protect among other things identity of witnesses
to avoid disclosure of highly personal and embarrassing. So he
probably reads this one.
Proctor Gamble appeals from a discovery protected order granted
by the district court of 20 denying access to the names and addresses
of women who gave the center for disease control personal information
of participants in the center's toxic shock syndrome studies.
So it sounds like this has to do with accessing names and addresses
of women who were participating in like a medical study relating
to toxic shock syndrome. Sure.
Hold on. What is the what is the actual thing they argue? Third
party witnesses. Okay. What is the actual thing they argue? Um
courts routinely fashion protective orders for the purposes of
shielding sensitive information. So is the is the idea that they
could never that is impossible. Is that the response? Despite
the foregoing reality which entirely neutral neutralizes Benell's
challenges to the proposed protective order plaintiff addresses
Benell's remaining arguments including his inference that plaintiff
lacks standing to request the that the identity of certain of
her witnesses remain confidential. Courts routinely fashion protective
orders for purposes of shielding sensitive information about
third party witnesses if so requested by the by a party to the
action. So this is them saying that when you said that third
party witnesses need to do this on their own or that that like
a party to the action shouldn't be doing this that they haven't
actually sought anonymity on their own. It's like no here are
examples where a party of the action is seeking anonymity on
behalf of a third party. Right? That's that's what the the purpose
of this is. It doesn't have to be relevant to harassment or even
be analogous to this case. It's literally saying you said this
is not possible to do and we're arguing it is and here's an example
of where it happened. Yes. requested party to the action and
then they say this case vers yellow. So they're saying that the
the a party to the case can seek anonymity for a third party
witness. That's what they're saying. So if that case has a party
to the case seeking anonymity for a third party witness and that's
what they're responding to, right? Because I believe Destiny's
thing here is there's no basis to is this wait which one which
one was it? Uh this is nonparty witnesses have not set anonymity
today. No third party or nonparty witness in this case has sought
any form of protection from the court. Plaintiff's attempt to
extend her own dose status to nonparties is procedurally improperly
and substantially unsupported.
So I don't even know where they're talking about like I don't
understand how this is. I don't I don't understand like what
the point of um this argument is. Limited cases in which courts
have permitted anity involve parties who establish a legally
cognisible interest. Typically a cause of action or defense sufficient
to implicate their personal privacy rights. here. By contrast,
the non-party witnesses have not demonstrated any such interest
either. So, oh, this would so legally cognable interest. So,
they're saying that basically there would have there would be
some interest is preventing your personal identifying information
from being exposed like a a a valid interest. So, like it's weird
how this splits off because I think I absolutely have an interest
here where I've been like threatened directly by the plaint or
sorry, the defendant in this case, right? So, and like explicitly
threatened with the kind of information that would be supplied
in a nonprotected affidavit, right? Like that's explicitly what
I've been threatened. So, I believe I totally have an interest.
Um, and then I think this wouldn't be the thing to use to protect
the other witnesses as far as I know. It cites you at the bottom.
Are you talking about Destiny's thing? Yeah, I remember that.
That it had me um it had like a link to one of my things, right?
This one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We we I think we covered this
on stream, but like I I think I I might have only posted on Twitter
about this or sorry, I might have only posted on Discord about
this. This is obviously right. I think by the way, this is why
Destiny was so mad about me saying, "No, no, no. I actually do
think it's uh I actually do feel in danger, right?" Cuz he's
hoping that he can get me to go, "Oh, no, no. This guy's like,
"I'm not worried about anything. No, I am worried about something.
No, I am worried about one of his community members harming me."
No, I think that's totally legitimate. I think he has threatened
me. He said I should be killed and he's tried to dox me. I think
I absolutely am within my rights to feel under threat by that.
You
[__] you. Right. But I think he's he's trying to
get me to like I don't know. He's he's trying to imply that like
I have no concern here. That's just not true. I obviously have
concern here. What does it mean that when they say extend her
own dose status? So I think they're trying to say that under
USC I think they were trying to argue that under USC 6851
that that that provides protections for people. And I think maybe
that's like the form of form of protection she sought to get
dose status originally and then from there nothing changed I
think. But we'll see. We will see. We will see. Wait, was he
complaining that you shouldn't feel threatened after calling
you before your death? No, he's saying that because I laughed
that they exposed my avatar that meant exhibit B. Hold on. They're
arguing that because I laugh here. The name is redacted.
They're arguing that because I laughed here I feel no serious
threat.
And it's like, no, I I just don't think like this avatar being
exposed is what is causing me thread, right? Yeah. Avatar is
not redacted. This was funny, but it's like a different thing
than what's going on with the rest of stuff. What a weak argument.
Yeah, obviously a weak argument. It's funny that a lot of people
can't see that it's a weak argument. That's very funny. How does
these How does this even make it into legal dogs, man? I don't
know. It's pretty goofy. It's a goofy thing. It's just a goofy
goofy goofy thing. Yeah. Anyway, where were we on Pixie's thing?
Hold on. We were around here.
I don't remember where we were. Oh, we were looking at his stupid
He was looking through this, right? So, I'm guessing this is
just going to be about third party witnesses having the ability
to
uh identity of witnesses to avoid disclosure of highly personal
embarrassing information. I would say personally identifying
information, right? Um
h what's the argument here that the evidence? So, the argument
here would be no. I don't understand what the difference in the
argument is from a mechanical standpoint. Let's let's listen
because for for this one it's like okay it's hiding the identities
of women who are in a study on toxic shock syndrome. So it's
like some medical details right some but I mean why do you want
your medical details hidden because it's personal right I think
details broadly there's some argument to the court that details
are things that are personal you should be able to hide as well
and for some for a couple of the witnesses they're providing
explicit like details. Yes. It' be even funnier if they silhouetted
your avatar and further filings. No, they shouldn't around affirming
um blanket protected order issued to protect my other thing.
Okay, this is the one. It's just ridiculously stupid. Let's see.
Let's see the argument. What do they say to prove that protective
order? Oh, they do say here though. The court they use 26 C,
right? Which provides that the court for a good cause shown may
make any order which justice requires to protect a party or person
from annoyance, embarrassment, oppression, or undue burden or
expense. So they're using 26 C the same thing for the same reason
right it's the same underlying reason that's why I said mechanically
I believe it's the same thing and it is it's 26 C hey there's
good cause to prevent uh annoyance embarrassment oppression or
undue burden or expense
obviously the law's basic presumption is that the public is entitled
to every person's evidence that's your starting point is that
when there's a filing in court um the presumptive starting point
is that everything is public that's work we start to make arguments
for why something ought to be sealed or protected so Destiny
would have to say why those details that are there Right. If
it protects medical records, OMFG he's pro, you are once again
like participating conversation that has nothing like you are
literally so far off. You have no idea where the conversation
is, but good luck. Um, again, using rule 26 C, Destiny has to
argue why the protecting these identities would not protect the
person from annoyance, embarrassment, oppression, or undue burden
or expense. Saying, "Hey, this person, I had a relationship with
them. I recorded a video with them. They shared it non-consensually."
He has to explain why that information would not be information
that would cause them um what what do you call it? Uh annoyance,
embarrassment, oppression or undue burden or expense. I think
it's just obvious that it would. So I don't know I I don't know
where his argument is going to go here. However, that a court
for good question may make any order which justice requires a
person
or motion at a good cause of super balance interest approach
to the rule. PNG's interest related to trial preparation and
defense. Those are important interests and great care must be
taken to avoid unnecessary infringement. Evolort.
Uh evil Morty, thank you for the one month is was that oh man,
this is your first month ever subscribing individually. Let's
go on kick. Thank you very much. Appreciate it, dude. Notice
we're not here willing
actression in holding the center outweigh the Okay. First, the
center's purpose is the protection of the public's health. Central
to this purpose is the ability to conduct uh probing scientific
and social research supported by a population willing to submit
death questioning. Okay. So they did all this work here. Yeah.
So this is actually again a very mechanically similar question.
It's like hey uh so with regards to misconduct
with regards to witnesses and misconduct uh situations
right I think it has been ruled that they want to allow people
that basically there is a chilling effect on people participating
in cases as witnesses or anything else if their private details
will be tied to their identity. And so we want to give these
people protections. I think it's the broad argument Pixie's legal
team was making and it seems like they're using the same thing
with 26C to make the same legal argument just without uh medical
information. It's just with details. Yes. Is there a distinguish?
There is no distinction done here. I'm we're literally reading
it right now. There is no distinction here. Uh Kingler,
you understand that the in the the disconnect here, Kingler,
actually Kingler, join VC. I'll discuss this with you on VC if
you want, but I'm not going to discuss this with you in chat.
So, you can hop in the waiting room if you want in the VC and
we can talk and but I'm not going to do it through chat. It's
a waste of time. That makes sense. But it's funny that they would
site that case. I'm also not I'm not going to ban you if you
don't hop in VC, but uh yeah, hop in VC if you want to if you
want to have this argument or have this conversation. I can explain
to you exactly why it's a silly argument and we'll we'll just
walk through it really really calmly
with all of the the care and patience in the world. Anyway,
courts routinely fashion protective orders for purposes of shielding
sensitive information about third party witnesses if so requested
by a party to the action. See, for example, Fanssworth and Proctor
and Campbell. That's a crazy if you if you're ever bored the
citations that plaintiffs law firm which might maybe they all
do. Wait, why why is that a bad argument?
Why is the argument there bad? It's literally constructed in
the exact same way. Like it is mechanically the same thing. Hey,
if we were to allow witnesses who participated in a study, if
we're to allow their their identities to be exposed in a toxic
shock syndrome thing, these people basically didn't take their
tampons out, right? If we're allowed if we're allowing those
witnesses ident or sorry, those people's identities to be exposed,
that'd be really bad. That would probably like that might harm
people participating in scientific studies in the future. It's
the same thing with uh with misconduct. It's like it might actually
harm people from getting justice, like do justice in the future.
Witnesses will not participate in these cases unless they can
have their identities protected from the public. It's it's mechanically
the exact same. I don't understand how you could possibly say
that that is a poor argument. Unless somebody can tell me where
I'm where am I misunderstanding.
Where's where's the difference in terms of mechanism at play
here? Like in terms of uh oh, how would I say like the abstractions
that are being argued? It's the same. Do um AI. Maybe it's literally
all just AI and that's all this firm does. He literally just
read something that like lines up perfectly and goes that's insane
that they're trying to use this as a case that they could site.
That's stupid. All every other so funny. Sometimes it's for protect
don't do what they say they're for. Sometimes they lose. Um it's
just like it's just ridiculously stupid. Okay, here's King Gingler.
Hey Gingler. How's it going? Hey y'all. Cool. I'm ready to have
my mind changed. Yeah, sure. So what what you So I'll read what
you said. Uh I I'm open to being wrong, but the reason why it
doesn't feel like a weak argument to me is because a person distressed
about being identified, but laughs when their participation is
identified seems in congruous. Okay. What's in congress precisely?
So if uh the way that I imagine if I was presenting to this someone
again I know nothing about legal stuff at all but sure uh this
person is doesn't want to participate or doesn't want to publicly
participate because they fear for their safety
um however their whatever you call it the do you think I don't
want to participate
in this general line of discussion because I fear for my safety
in a general sense Would that would anybody really make that
argument with me right now or you with the law? I'm saying that
I am currently participating and receiving like the the harassment
from Destiny without participating
fully in the legal case. Right. But I am still doing it. I'm
still reading documents right now. So So is anybody actually
arguing that I would not participate in this unless my my identity
was protected, unless my pseudonym was protected? No. Right.
Um what what if it's reframed where where you're discussing this
online in a very public setting? You're you're being very aggressive
in your discussion about it, but actually participating being
in in contact with the lawyers um is a step beyond like beyond
the pale like you're not contented about this. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Why is it a step beyond the pale? Why is it a step beyond
the pale? Yes. From your perspective or from Destiny's perspective,
from your perspective, it it heightens the likelihood that someone
would be upset with you and might, you know, cause aggression
towards you. Nope. I don't think so. Why? Lots of people lots
of people make content about because the person in question who
actually harasses people involved in this case has already called
for my death and tried to dox me. So, I don't think anything
I could do as far as participating in this case actually goes
beyond that or would go beyond that. Then like I I think that
level of harassment is going to stay fairly consistent. I don't
even think people will be significantly more mad. I think people
would be less mad about me participating in the case quietly
than me covering it consistently. That's that's fine. How does
how does that square with with your with the idea of well he
doesn't seem that distressed about it because because you you
haven't actually because you haven't actually said why. It's
because I agree with you that it's a step beyond to participate
in the legal case, but you haven't said why. I thought when I
when I asked you why, I thought you would say the reason, but
you didn't. So, I can fill it in or if you want to try again.
It's not the reason you said. It's not that people would be more
mad at me. Not people that Destiny would be more mad. Yeah. No,
I don't even think that's true. I think he's already about as
mad as he can be. There's a there's a reason, but it's a reason
why going through
online. It's It's not about how mad Destiny is. Don't worry about
it. Um, there's a reason why participating in the legal case
without any protections
is a step in like a step beyond what I'm willing to do. Can you
tell me why? Because it I I again I I have no formal basis for
because it would involve using my legal name to file an affidavit.
Right. So it would like put pen to paper your identity. Yes.
It makes it more and you want some additional like legal barrier
to him leaking that
even though he could do it now um or he's tried to do it now
but that the actual putting it on paper having legal precedence
that I don't know if I'm using the right words that he would
get in like big for doing it. Yeah. Because he's failed so far.
But now he would have that information directly and there's I
mean he wouldn't even have to do it himself, right? If I have
no protection at all, it would just be my real name there with
no redaction. So, in a way, this is actually kind of you protecting
yourself by participating
in this. This is this is you like picking up. No, I think I can
still get doxed. This is it's not me protecting myself because
I don't need to protect myself in this. I don't even need to
participate, right? I I might be able to participate and provide
information. I'm not sure. I I haven't done like an interview
with Pixie's lawyers. I don't know what they want to ask. I don't
know what direction they're going. I don't know what their legal
arguments are, right? But but like uh how would I put this? Like
I I don't feel like it's safe for me to do that because obviously
this person has said I deserve to be killed and they said they
would publish my information the second they had it. Right. That
is you know that he said that verbatim. Yes.
Uh that he would publish your information if he had it. As soon
as he had it. Yes. Um I'll take your word for it. I just remember
him him saying uh whose information I I hope he has soon. Yeah.
Yeah. No, he also said he would publish it as soon as he get
it. Somebody asked if he had my docs. He said no. If I did, I
would have already published it. Oh, I think I do remember that.
Okay. Um, give me give me
on your No worries. So, I'm saying given those threats, I think
it's appropriate to have a protective order that doesn't give
my identity to him or at minimum protects it from the public
and makes it bad for him to leak it. Do you think that's unreasonable?
I don't think it's unreasonable. I'm thinking in terms of Okay.
arguments. Give me like two I don't want to put dead air on your
stream. Just give me like two seconds to think. Sure. It feels
like you're Maybe this isn't a bad thing, but it it seems like
you're relying on two explanations
as to why you've gone the route that you have. And for one,
it's because All right. I'm trying to figure out why this doesn't
make any sense to me. Sure. So I I would just ask you what part
So if they blocked up my avatar here, if they blocked up my avatar
and they hid my pseudonym, would I be more safe? Uh yeah. Why?
because you're you're part Oh, I I thought this was a I thought
we would agree here, but uh because this is a we both agreed
that this is a step beyond of your your participation in the
case being like revealed and therefore this is more than just
making content out of it, which a lot of people are, but they're
not getting been talking about my participation in the case for
months now. Yeah. Why why would this screenshot change anything?
First of all, if the screenshot So the screenshot really doesn't
change anything in the first place, but even if it did, even
if this avatar was hidden, um I'm literally talking about how
I'm going to this this the screenshot that they're using here
is me saying I'm going to talk about something publicly on stream
and then I and then it's because Dr. Myself calling for my death.
So now I'm one of two people essentially and then you could just
go and look at this date or some date around there and see who
talked about this publicly on those dates. Uh, so if if I'm afraid
for for my safety and and and my participation in in this legal
spat, for one, um, I wouldn't want my identity revealed and I
wouldn't want my participation in the court revealed.
um fact that one of those protections are taken away.
I I can just see someone being like, "Well, obviously he's not
that upset about it because now he knows for sure that you are
at least in communication with Pixie's lawyers." Now, except
Hold on. Except the the clear threat that I see is Destiny knowing
who I am and directing harassment to me in real life. I've never
once complained about Destiny responding to anything I've said
on stream. I do complain about him making things up because that's
mostly what he does. He just makes things up whole cloth like
lies blatantly to his audience and they eat it up completely.
So that I do complain about, but in terms of Destiny like being
mad at me as a pseudonym or being mad at my like platform, being
mad at me as a content creator, I'm totally willing to accept
that, right? And possibly that like there are threats that happen
to me, but obviously it's like the way I make money and there's
a whole bunch of other things going on there. So like I'm willing
to accept that. So I already was here saying I'm going to speak
publicly these exact things, right? So nobody, nothing I've actually
provided in any way is not something I've said publicly so far.
Like I'm literally already here. The threat the threat here is
him obtaining my identity and using that to direct harassment
andor harm to me. That is what the threat is.
I I'm I'm I'm kind of in a in a like a legal mindset like what
I'm imagining them to say in the court. I mean, you and I can
spec can have like a little bit more freedom of what we what
our actual argument could be of Y, X, Y, and Z. Destiny already
knows this. Destiny can already do this. But I'm saying like
I don't I don't even understand what you're saying at all. You're
actually just saying nonsense right now. You're a legal mindset.
I don't You're not a YouTuber, so can you just say what you mean?
What What are you trying to argue right now? I imagine you and
I having an argument about this will be a lot different than
a than a lawyer versus a lawyer in a courtroom, right? A lawyer
to a judge says, "This guy is laughing even though it's been
revealed that he is uh participating in this in this uh case.
Therefore, he's not very afraid.
I've been cited in the documents multiple times and Destiny is
already directing maximum harassment towards me. There is no
threat to my pseudonym being involved with this case. My pseudonym
is already involved with the case. That's not what I'm seeking
to protect. I'm not seeking to protect JC Jstk.
Never once sought to protect that. What I'd seek to protect is
my actual real life identity so that I could participate in the
case directly. And that is the argument they're making. That's
the argument I make. That's the argument they make. The only
who's engaging with a different argument is Destiny because he
has no actual argument against what the real argument is, right?
So, he's made up a straw man and tried to pretend that if he
beats that, uh, everybody thinks he's a big smart boy. Straw
man is is the argument that I'm is the argument that I'm talking
about right now as a straw man. Yeah. Like, nobody's arguing
that that my that my pseudonym needs to be protected. Nobody's
argued that. Nobody's made that point. In fact, literally, if
they had my identity blocked off here, my I'm no less exposed.
They could not include this at all. But then, what evidence do
they have? Right. I don't need my pseudonym protected. I mean,
I understand you're what you're saying. I can accept that that's
true, that you've made that calculation and you've made that
decision. But I mean, from a a lawyer making the argument, is
that going to be con I'm just arguing what's convincing to to
someone going in cold. Do you think Do you think lawyers are
incapable of like making any sort of argument to people? Why
Why would this fail to be Why would you think this would fail
being made this argument being made to a judge? Why would a judge
not understand? Why would a judge fail to understand the difference
between a pen name and a full legal name? Judges aren't,
right? They have some level of intelligence. They were able to
become judges. I assume almost every judge in America would know
the difference between a pen name and a full legal name. Uh do
you think that's incorrect? Do you think that's insane?
No, I just don't think it really has anything to do with with
what I'm saying. Okay. Uh so the argument is I have a pseudonym
that doesn't apply to my real legal name and for and Destiny's
arguing that the revelation of my pseudonym which was already
participating in the case publicly and I publicly talked about
this exact thing here where I said I talked to Pixie's lawyers
right I had already revealed that information on my own as the
pseudonym as the pen name so where is the where's the protection
I'm seeking it's only on my real legal name yes right but why
do you think a judge would fail to understand that I'm just so
now you understand so The core misunderstanding that you think
could happen is the judge might not know the difference between
a pseudonym or a pen name and a full legal name. Right. Okay.
So, where is your confusion? Go. The my confusion is is your
is them showing a video of you laughing but you also saying that
you're in distress. So, I mean you can you can explain the difference
between
the uh the JSTL JSTLK and your real name, but a a real person
who's actually in distress would be like Now he knows.
I'm not saying that you didn't do that. I'm not saying
but you understand. You understand that this is me already letting
him. I already month a month ago said I spoken to these people
and this is my exact thing. Doxing myself plus Destiny calling
for my death is too much. Doxing myself. What does that mean?
You're you're looking at the reason. I literally state the reason
I don't want to do it right here. Doxing myself revealing my
real identity. They just need the translation of doxing myself,
right? Plus Destiny calling for my death, which he has not disputed.
He's never once said, "No, no, no. I didn't say that." Right?
That is the reason. So me laughing here, there's not me doxing
myself. In fact, I'm expressing to somebody here to Pixie, it
seems that I that I will speak about this publicly. I will say
this is my reasoning publicly. I I don't have any concern about
this information being reached uh revealed publicly because I
have myself revealed it publicly. You you took you took steps.
No aspect of this. Okay, go ahead. Oh, wait. You almost got something.
Go ahead. To hide your identity, hide your participation.
And one of those barriers was removed. Which steps did I Which
Hold on. Which steps did I take? Yes. Let's go. Uh, well, you
you're behind a pseudonym and and you you know, you don't bring
Pixie on. Uh, you're I don't I don't think you're publicly saying
whether you're in communication with Pixie's lawyers or not.
So, uh, do you mind if I say I sat down with your attorneys?
I just wanted to say it today. Bretler just filed a motion in
opposition and I'm going to say this is precisely why I refuse
to give an affidavit because doxing myself plus Destiny calling
for my death is too much. Are you not reading the text on the
screen? Yeah. Okay. Can you connect the dots for it? Oh, you
said I don't You just said the words. I don't know if you've
said publicly that you've connected with Pixie attorneys. I've
already explained that I did this. This happened on stream. This
happened live on stream. So what were the what was the point
of blocking out your the
moniker on the screenshot? I have no idea. Okay. Okay. So if
you already publicly said that you are in communication with
Pixie's lawyers
um let me I guess that does change and that that was where my
confusion was I suppose. Okay. Do you think this would be confusing
for a judge to understand that that basically my concern here
is having my real name in the hands of somebody who's called
for my death and I said they would publish that information as
soon as they possibly can. No, I can accept your reasoning. I
think any reasonable person can accept it. I'm just I'm talking
in terms of when I said legal mine in in terms of a convincing
argument like you have a video of you laughing. What you what
you actually what you actually mean is optics wise in the court
of debate bros it I have a video of you laughing. I can say whatever
I want. You're not talking about legal cases or lawyers. You're
saying optics-wise in the court of bait bros in a Twitch panel.
I could totally make somebody believe that you don't actually
feel threat. U maybe maybe I am saying that. I just don't like
I said, I don't know anything about legal stuff, but I imagine
they're going to show this video. Well, it's in the
they cited it. Yeah. So the and that'll be the argument. I just
wanted to hear your argu argument as to why that would be unconvincing.
I mean, I can accept that your logic makes sense. I don't know
if it it trumps the the video of you laughing personally, but
um also like on a base level, Destiny has already tried to dox
me. He's already called for my death. Those things have happened,
right? What more do what more can I do? How how is me going,
"Oh my god, he's really he's really going to hurt me.
Oh, he's really going to hurt me now." Do you think that would
be an effective strategy for preventing somebody from harassing
me? more effective than you laughing for sure. It could be a
video. You're just you're just objectively wrong. And and Destiny
himself makes the exact opposite uh argument
that you don't you don't expose what actually concerns you on
the internet because people will use that to hurt you, right?
That's like something Destiny says constantly, something Dan
said constantly. So what is the upside of going, "Oh, I really
think they're going to get me
on the internet."
Yeah. nothing on the internet wise, but legal legal wise, I can
imagine there's plenty of upside of of showing your frame of
mind that you're actually scared that this is actually affecting
you. And the guy continues to keep going. But now they can just
point to what are you talking about? He's laughing. He's having
a good time. This is all content. Yeah, I should open every every
stream in tears. He's going to get me. Not for your internet
legal team. Oh my god. Not for Yeah, not for your stream. I agree.
That's not a good approach. Well, I I unfortunately, you know,
I realize this is crazy, but I have some faith, some amount of
faith in America's legal system that if Pixie's team makes this
argument correctly to explain the difference between like a pen
name and a real name, it's by the way, it's the exact same thing.
So, Destiny relies on this total um fabrication that like a pen
name and audim
and a real name are the same. He uses it to try to say Pixie's
legal team didn't protect Abby in any way. He tries to use it
in a bunch of different ways to say like, "Oh, actually, this
is like they've totally doxed this person." It's like, bro, you're
not doxing like uh Kirish or some big VTuber. You're not doxing
Oh, what is her name? Vivebe. You're not doxing VBE by putting
VBE in a court document. Okay, obviously. Especially when Vivebe
is in logs in that court document saying, "Hey, I'm Vivebe and
like I'm going to go live on my Twitch stream and talk about
this at this exact time." Isn't he mostly just talking about
like their own inconsistency when applying like the Jane Doe
moniker or the Pixie moniker? Isn't that No, the No, they've
they've applied the Pixie moniker to this case from the the start.
Pixie is not He can say Pixie as much as he likes. Pixie was
in the initial complaint. It literally says in the initial complaint,
who goes by the screen name online of Pixie. Oh, am I just misremembering
where they where they were trying to hide the Pixie thing, too?
They were just trying to strictly go back for yourself and so
you're remembering what Destiny told you. That's true. I'm sorry.
Like that unironically like you you obviously would have seen
this. You obviously would have seen it at the time. You're just
not seeing it. Uh, yeah. I mean, if it's there, I'll take your,
like I said, I'll take your word for it. And I don't I don't
I really don't have the mind for this kind of thing whatsoever.
Okay. Okay. I'm sorry. Listen, I'm sorry. Okay. You're good.
You're good. You don't have to You're good. You don't have to
do I'm not I'm not I that uh I don't have that dog in me. I don't
want to I don't want to keep people on my stream. Okay.
That's not what I'm We'll get Queen in here next time and he
Yeah, Queen would lose it. Queen would lose it right now. All
right. Okay. All right. Well, thanks for coming on. Enjoy the
rest of your stream. I will talk to you later. Bye-bye. Okay.
Well,
I don't know. It seems like so clear to me, but maybe it's just
not clear to other people. Crazy stuff. I can't believe this
is the first month evil Morty's ever subscribed individually.
That's a little crazy. How does that How does that happen? That's
wild. I wonder if something different happened here. Okay. All
right.
Where were we here? Did we make it through? We didn't make it
through this document. Okay. We got to finish this document.
There's some more case citations here. Maybe this would be funny
to go through or something eventually.
Um, this one was a Pixie citation. I can't imagine he goes through
one of his own citations and talks about how disanalogous it
is. That would be quite funny. Hunter, no, no, no, no. That's
actually just totally wrong. Nobody is actually trying to prevent
these people from being or from being subpoenaed or like being
a part of a discovery. That's not They've said explicitly in
all of their documents, no, we're not hiding the identities from
you to prevent you from discovering them. We're not we're not
doing any of this. You can subpoena these people. We will give
them to we give these identities to your legal council. We just
want them protected from the public. I think in some cases possibly
protected from Destiny himself. Uh the argument was basically
because I laughed when I saw this filing that um that I should
be able to have my identity protected that I'm not actually concerned
for my safety at all. He called his own lawyers. I want to see
that. I do too, but I just don't know if I'm going to go through
the whole thing here. It's getting late. I got to finish some
stuff up though. What do we What are we finishing? This guyel's
challenges to meet and confer process have been waved and are
in an event wholly unsupportable.
Further highlighting Banel's ill intentions, his opposition raises
two confusing challenges to the party's meet and confer efforts.
First, Banell essentially postulates that a pre-filing conference
could only have been proper if the movement had agreed with the
nonmovement's position. Uh, docket entry 92 at 2 to3. This position
defies common sense, especially because Oh, right. Um, obviously
if they didn't have any differences, they they wouldn't they
wouldn't even need to file a motion. Second, Benell complains
about alleged discrepancies in the proposed protective orders,
but he cites to no authorities for the proposition that a motion
for protective order must be denied if the final proposed protective
order is not identical to the version previously served. In any
event, this argument has been waved for Banell's failure to adequately
brief it. Banell did not even address it in the argument section
of his response. Fails to elaborate on his position. Does not
cite to any authorities in support thereof and does not claim
to be prejudiced by the alleged discrepancies in the draft protective
orders. Zavdo versus Iberia Lineius Ar. Oh Jesus, that's a long
one. Arguments made in pass. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think
we read almost all of this. To the contrary, the only party that
is prejudiced here is plaintiff for being forced to brief an
issue contained in a prior draft order proposed uh prior draft
proposed order and which issue Banell mischaracterizes. Irrespective
of waiver, Banell's bold proposition that the court should decline
to enter the requested order, docket entry 92 at 7 on the basis
that a prior draft order provides for anonymity of plaintiff's
witnesses if so requested by them is not only illogical and unsupportable,
but smacks them with bad faith and further butresses the fear
of plaintiff and other victims being further victimized by Banell
and his intentions to continue to harass and threaten them in
connection with this litigation. I totally read this already.
So, what the am I reading right now? I don't understand. I read
that whole thing
Hunter, that's true. But, uh, many of the witnesses have already
had their stuff sealed, right?
Is the PS stuff over? Yeah. Yeah. The the Yep, that stuff's over.
That was earlier. Kuryoko,
welcome though. Welcome, welcome, welcome.
even if Destiny wins, he still loses in lawyer fees. Uh, I hope
that he actually loses. You finished the dock? I did not finish
the dock. Get the out of here. Oh, I did finish the dock.
You're right. I did finish the dock. God. All right. All right.
All right.
Sounds good. So, like here they're saying um affirming blanket
protective order issued. Enter Aaliyah, which I think means among
other things, right? That's what that means, right? Identity
witnesses. Cool. All right, I don't need any more of this. And
guys, I think that's uh that's it for the stream tonight.
Um I'm thinking I think Cherry's back tomorrow, I think. I'm
not totally sure. If not, we'll see what's going on. Um I'm not
totally sure. I think so, though. I think so. So, we'll see here.
Really off.
Malik's live, it looks like. Raid Malik. Yeah, Raid Mal. Good.
All right. We're Malik. I'm out. We'll talk to you guys later.
Have a good night. Have a good night, guys. Okay, be back tomorrow.
Okay, be back tomorrow. I might start starting a bit earlier.
We'll we'll see. I'm not 100% sure yet. Okay, I love you guys.
I'll be back tomorrow. Have a good night. Good night. Good night.
Good night. Also, perm going off in the Discord. I hope you guys
enjoyed your I hope you guys enjoyed your temporary reprieve
from the fascist regime. Okay, image perms gone. Wait, are you
covering the Pisco stuff sometime? Um, I might go back and cover
some of the Pisco stuff. Probably pro maybe not Hunter, but I
might do Collins and we could like argue about it either way.
I might agree with you though that like probably there is reason
to believe that that's a one of the cases. And if he says like
99% chance it's um like view discrimination, that would be weird
to me. Okay, DM. All right, sounds good. Sounds good. All right,
hosting Malak and I'm out, guys. Have a good night. Bye-bye.
Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Don't
call Malak a streamer. That's rude, bro. Okay. All right, talk
to you guys later. Bye bye. Bye. Bye.